let's keep the applause going for Team
20 the problem I'm a student and I'm
tested all the time um oftentimes in a
similar fashion multiple choice some
writing testing is boring but my
teachers feel compelled to mimic
summative accountability methods off
with my head oh okay assessment is a
necessary evil to hold teachers
accountable for their students learning
but the problem like Andre puts is that
students are over tested and multiple
choice tests they're not fun they're not
motivating and they just don't really
look like anything you see in the real
world the solution to this problem would
be to have more creative forms of
assessment assessments that are found
that are motivating that mimic
situations you see in real life so
things like interviews oral
presentations writing prompts the
problem with these types of assessments
is that grading can be subjective and
inconsistent and grading can take a
significantly long time so our strategy
for solving this problem is to take
machine learning algorithms and what
machine learning algorithms do is they
take the qualitative data that you get
from these creative forms of assessments
and they turn it into the quantitative
data that you need to fit into the
accountability metrics that you use like
graves so we would take this technology
and we would make it accessible to
teachers teach teachers how to use it
and what this would do it was it was it
would increase the teachers abilities to
use more creative forms of assessment in
their classrooms things like interviews
oral presentations writing prompts
because it would increase the
consistency for the grading and it would
reduce the amount of time that teachers
would need to spend grading in order to
use these types of assessments um but
there's more so we would start small
like maybe develop a program to grade
third grade writing prompts once we knew
it worked then we would scale up by
looking into other grades you know scale
over the entire k-12 system and also
develop programs to great other types of
assessments like oral transcripts
alright it's a little electric slide to
the left okay thank you guys machine
learning approaches require at least a
hundred examples in order to train the
system where would you be folk what
kinds of grades or subjects would you be
focused on so we would well we would be
focused on grades in the k-12 system so
we would start small like I said that
maybe third grade writing prompts and
the technology is improving so there's a
system that was developed this last year
that doesn't require hundreds of writing
samples in order to produce grades it's
getting better and better but we would
start small with maybe like a writing
prompt for a third grade classroom that
uses a textbook that's commonly used in
like all the third grade classrooms I'm
just to make sure that it work what does
the teacher lose and what is the teacher
gain right so what the teacher gains is
time the ability to use more creative
assessments a little bit more
flexibility and how she or he develops
his or her curriculum what the teacher
loses is a little bit of the personal
aspect she doesn't actually he or she
doesn't you know go through the process
of physically grading every single
student's assignment so you lose a
little bit of the feedback loop but you
gain more flexibility in terms of your
curriculum and the types of assessment
you can use
and see you imagine it going beyond
writing can it go to assessing projects
in some way or are going to write about
your project is how well so I can
envision it and being used to assess
interviews or oral presentations in
terms of projects because all it would
require is an additional piece of
software to transcribe that student
speech into a transcript and then have
the machine learning algorithm grade the
transcript as far as physical projects
I'm not sure have you measured
intangibles in a oral transcript of body
language and engagement of right so in
terms of that there would probably be
some components of the project that the
teacher would have to grant him or
herself it wouldn't be a VL end-all and
we wouldn't want it to be we would want
the street are the teacher to be
somewhere engagement of students like
project or presentation